meanwhile an article in The New York
Times suggests that the US House
Intelligence Committee chief might have
colluded with the whistleblower
according to the piece the anonymous CIA
agent spoke to Adam Schiff staff before
filing his complaint here's how Donald
Trump reacted to that there is a report
that came out just before you and
president Initiative walked out here
that the whistleblower met with a staff
member of Adam Schiff I love that
question being filed it shows that
Schiff is a fraud I think it's a scandal
that he knew before I go a step further
I think he probably helped write it the
only controversy the US House
Intelligence Committee chief has got
himself embroiled in as RT Zelia
Petrenko explains if there was an award
for the staunchest hater of President
Trump certainly this man would make it
to the list of nominees no need to
remind why all right just watch this for
a bit president was essentially tried to
coerce a Ford leader to help his
presidential campaign there seems to be
no floor below which this president can
drop serious and level of misconduct
about his fundamental betrayal our
president has told the American people
that yes I leaned on Ukraine to
manufacture dirt on my opponent and
obviously with that in mind it's a piece
of cake to guess what this guy's most
cherished dream is impeachment for the
mega man it may be that we undertaken
appeasement nonetheless that compels us
to travel down the road towards
impeachments those facts which are
uncontested at this point compel us to
move down the path of a formal
impeachment inquiry well if you try and
properly imagine yourself in mr. Schiff
shoes you'll probably say oh yeah what
he's up to is totally legit cuz mr.
Trump is on a mission to dig as much
dirt as possible on his most dangerous
Democrat political opponent and for the
president all means are good even if
it's done through a phone conversation
with Ukraine's president who mr. Trump
asked to once again hit the trail of Joe
Biden's son and so Adam Schiff was like
it is illegal improper of violation of
oath the violation of his
duty to defend our elections our
Constitution for the present to merely
ask for foreign interference in our
election well it's time to remind you of
a different phone conversation from 2017
between now not Donald Trump this time
Adam Schiff and supposedly the Speaker
of the Ukrainian Parliament the nature
of the compromise well there were a
pictures of naked Trump okay so you you
have recordings of both so check and
boosah
where they're discussing the
compromising material on mr. Trump
absolutely on that meaning or opening
told Flynn that all those compromising
materials will never released if Trump
will cancel all Russian sanctions okay
well obviously we would welcome a chance
to get copies of those recordings so we
will try to work with the FBI to figure
out along with your staff how we can
obtain copies of those oops I forgot to
mention something really important that
was a prank although it seems mr. Schiff
was so hungry for the Trump Cobra Matt
he totally fell for it Schiff was pretty
serious he wrote all of what we said on
the paper remembered all the detail
surely when you're looking for something
to get Trump out of there you're good to
cross any lines nothing improper or
probe worthy by the way speaking of
dealing with the Russians in some shape
or form as we know anyone who gets
themselves involved in that could be
compromised or spied on for the rest of
their lives mr. Schiff once spoke to us
RT RT made in Russia get it one of those
members of Congress leading the effort
is Adam Schiff from California he joined
me earlier I think I have the cumulative
impact of making the FISA Court much
more transparent should someone put him
under a federal probe for that he or his
assistants were probably talking to a
few Russians while the interview was
being arranged oh that was long before
Donald Trump showed up in the White
House politics should be fine then
Schiff is certainly a very
is also Trump's also accused him of
being shifty and shifty I think is a
much more apt description I mean what
was going on with Schiff and whose
pranksters that were he was dead and
maybe you say oh yeah we we've got some
naked pictures of Trump with some with
some Russian pokers do you want to see
them so yeah chief was ready to seize on
that whereas you know I think Trump was
asking you know I think perfectly
reasonable questions obviously he wants
to bring down Donald Trump he tried to
do it with Russia Gate I mean Adam
Schiff was really one of the key figures
in Russia okay and so now here he is
he's suddenly you know from Russia gate
is moved on to Ukraine gate
Trump's belief which i think is
reasonably based that the origin of
Russia gate is to be found in Ukraine
and he was asking since is help in
investigating this and in this case on
Ukraine gate is even flimsier than
Russia gate so I think that will
probably do a lot more damage
you